this is uh i look kind of funny pink
the singer if you remember her she um
hasn't made a good song in well forever
she's never made a good song but she
hasn't made a hit song in probably about
20 years in recent years she's taken to
just ranting about conservatives on
social media
a few weeks ago she's i think she was
the one who said that she doesn't want
pro-lifers to listen to her music at all
that's how much she hates us
a request which i am more than happy to
abide by in fact i i respect her request
so much that i have been respecting it
before 20 years before she even made it
that's how much i respect her as a
person
anyway she has a new song out called
irrelevant
in which she partly complains about
being called irrelevant which is
hilarious already but in the song and in
the music video um in her bid for
relevance she just throws every
woke
virtue singling thing she can into the
mix and she just throws them all
into a blender and mixes them together
and you you hear that in the song but
especially in the video which we'll play
a little bit of right now watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it might rain today
ash on the ground
took all the here we could take
and then burn it down
[Music]
now it's a real parade
we're all welcome now
as long as you feel afraid
that's what it's about
you can call me irrelevant insignificant
you can try to make me small
i'll be your heretic you hypocrite i
won't think of you at all
[Music]
okay so you get the idea uh we start
with obama you know aoc pro-abortion
protesters they're the good guys then we
get to the bad guys and she lumps in
pro-lifers conservative supreme court
justices and goes right to images of
nazis and the clan later on she shows
the january 6th riots uh like i said the
whole kitten caboodle there but but
here's the point that i have to make
again because it's it's um
it's really interesting to see this kind
of happen
art on the left
music films tv all of that
it's all now headed in the same
direction as christian music and
christian films
in fact this song even sounds kind of
like a christian like a christian rock
song just the words are very different
and the imagery is very different the
message is different but the sound
is like something you would hear on one
of these christian music stations given
recent scotus wins it feels like the
pendulum may be swinging back to a time
when the nuclear family was situated at
the center of american life where real
conversation learning and growth began
at home with your family gathered around
the table and president ronald reagan's
farewell address he said all great
change in america begins around the
dinner table so you got to bring your
family to the dinner table with good
ranchers good ranchers cares deeply
about providing families with high
quality meat at a reasonable price their
mission is to bring people to the table
making those shared moments with your
loved ones easy accessible and most
importantly delicious good ranchers
ships 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the u.s right to your door
plus when you subscribe your price your
price is locked in for the life of your
subscription no inflation when it comes
to good ranchers good ranchers not only
supports american agriculture they're
also
big fans of the daily water and big
supporters they sponsor all of our shows
so you got to check them out use my code
matt for 30 off plus free shipping on
your order take advantage of this offer
invest in time shared with your family
you're going to buy meat anyway so you
might as well buy great meat from folks
who support all that we do here go to
goodranchers.com to start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious food also if you
already bought from good ranchers well
show me what you're making post a photo
of your meal i'd love to see it and tag
me and my friends of good ranchers so
they can see it too
the circle is going all the way around
and now mainstream art
makes the same mistake that christian
music and film has made for many years
and that is putting the message above
the art itself going message first art
second
and then you you end up with this kind
of lame repetitive uninteresting content
and it hits the messaging notes that you
want but it's not very good art and i
think one of the reasons why that's
happening on the left
is that
great art requires some friction right
it requires some resistance some
frustration
in order to be created i think most
great art is born partly from
frustrations think about all the
all of the revolutions in the music
industry um when new sounds and artists
and musical genius burst onto the scene
they always had
some sort of
uh they always had to push their way in
against forces that wanted to keep them
out there's the stereotype of the
tortured artist right and there's a lot
of truth to that stereotype it might not
hold in every case but it holds in many
of them
the problem is that if you're on the
left
especially if you're relatively wealthy
and well off
then you experience no friction um you
are not standing against the cultural
current at all but you're floating on it
easily and softly that's one of the
reasons why you see especially these
aging pop stars who maybe arguably were
a little bit counter cultural in the 70s
80s and some of the 90s not very much
but a little bit
and then they had some success they made
a lot of money and and now they're
living in a culture living partly in the
culture they created
um and they're very comfortable and
they're not counter culture anymore at
all anymore they're now the vanguards of
the culture the culture they created and
so there's just there's no friction
there there's no frustration to to
create great art they have nothing left
to say
as evidence partly by this pink song
although in fairness she never really
had anything to say i guess well if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button and ring the bell to
get more content like it if you're
craving more content go watch or listen
to my full show at dailywire.com spotify
or wherever you get your podcast
you